Let's sleep here.
Spike said.
Is that the farmer over there?
Billy asked.
I don't think so.
Spike said.
I think it's a scarecrow. But he does not scare me!
Said Spike.
That night, Spike did get scared.
First, an arm moved.
Spike hid under the corn.
Then, both arms and the corn moved.
Spike hid under the tractor.
Spike, why are you hiding?
Billy asked.
I'm hiding from the farmer.
Said Spike.
Billy thought. He knew it was not a farmer.
He knew it was a scarecrow.
He thought about why the scarecrow moved.
The wind stopped blowing.
The corn and the scarecrow stopped moving.
Everything was still.
Billy said.
Now I know. The wind moved the scarecrow and the corn.
It is not the farmer moving.
Billy said to Spike.
It is the wind moving the scarecrow.
Said Billy.
Don't be scared.
Oh, no! Silly me.
Said Spike.